hey everybody welcome to live Kony with
Jessie I'm Jessie and today we're going
to do some react stuff I'm very very
excited because we have a launch date
for this website that we've been working
on this is now stream number 96 this
project I'm just so so ready to launch
this thing I want people to see it we've
put so much work into this I want to
know either whether they like it or hate
it I want to know I wanted people to
actually use it and get feedback and so
I've been putting in a lot of work
I've been working a lot from home and
I've been going to a lot of meetings and
unfortunately doing paperwork
so it's been a while since I streamed
also this was a short week here in the
United States Monday was a national
holiday so a lot of people had the day
off including me so that's why I haven't
been streaming a lot I'm gonna try to do
better next week hopefully next week
it's gonna be hectic though so we're
gonna plan on launching next Wednesday
that is September 12th
I believe so September 12th is gonna be
the launch date probably I'm thinking
sometime in the afternoon not like too
late cuz I want to get out of here you
know on time but maybe maybe like very
early afternoon something like that I
think would be a good launch so let me
show you what what my schedules like to
get this finished before we jump into
some code you switch to my screen here
and I'm gonna zoom in hopefully you'll
be able to see this okay so this is my
Trello board where y'all can see
everything I'm working on it's I believe
it's a public Trello board so I'm gonna
copy and paste this link into the live
chat so you can check that out let me
know
I don't see I'm gonna see any activity
in the live chat so all right cool I see
something now I was worried that it
wasn't working for me so if you want to
check out my Trello board and how I have
this set up feel free but basically what
needs to happen before we launch is
everything in this in progress and ready
for dev columns this stuff here this to
do I've left things in here that don't
need to be done yet it can be put off
till after work after we've launched so
basically I have what do we have here so
my estimates are in the dark blue in
terms of how many Pomodoro sessions
it'll take me to complete these so
that's 25 minute sessions so I'm I'm
hoping that I can get at least ten
sessions in per day per workday and at
that rate then I should definitely be
able to get this stuff ready for launch
now some things that aren't on here are
like I guess late deployment type of
things so getting like domain names
pointed to the right place you know
things like that so it is gonna take
longer than this to get it ready but and
I'm also hoping that some of these items
will take less time than I've estimated
so today specifically we're gonna create
a landing page for admission staff so
the first page is just going to be a
list of all the staff members and
admissions and then the next component
that we're gonna make is going to be the
component just for a particular staff
member okay so if you click on an item
in the list it will take you to the page
for that staff member this is going to
follow the same pattern that we used for
the for the faculty components so the
first thing we're going to do is look at
that the faculty list component
and then the faculty page component and
first thing we'll do is see in this
potential you could save us a lot of
time could we just modify those and use
them as well if the answer is yes that's
what we'll do otherwise what we'll do is
copy and paste make new components and
just edit them to fit our use case here
okay I see some people saying hello and
hey did dijanna let me know if I'm
pronouncing that right
dijanna says hi from Bosnia hey how's it
going I got some other questions I'm
gonna do a Pomodoro session first of
coding and then I'm gonna take a break
and I'm gonna answer all the questions
so if you ask something just hang on for
a little bit we're gonna do 25 minutes
of code to start then we'll do questions
and then we'll switch switch back and
forth okay if you you're saying hello -
Alex Richard hey how's it going okay all
right great now we have a decent number
of viewers now 77 all right hey
everybody I'm assuming there's some new
people here how's it going
if you are new this is my everyday work
I work at a small University and we are
making a new main website let me give
you a link so you can check out the site
as we work on it
I'm gonna paste this in now and you can
check out the site navigate to whatever
page you want inspect it in your own
browser and I'll double check to see if
this works
all right cool so people are getting on
there hey Quincy's here how's it going
Quincey did that link come through I'm
gonna paste that one more time because
it's all it said I had an error so okay
people are clicking on it now awesome
I'm gonna move over to the code and
let's check out those components that we
that I mentioned just a minute ago
so this faculty list component and then
also the faculty
oops
faculty is now we're using next Jas so
any of these components we have in our
pages folder is actually gonna be like a
route right so work on the I guess we'll
work on the faculty list first okay so
in our faculty list let's take our
styles and move them down so if you've
been watching you know I've slowly been
moving all of our style objects down to
the bottom because I think it makes it
easier to figure out what a components
knowing when you open it up immediately
you don't have as much scrolling going
on so we'll get that out of the way and
we see here that we're using the next
Jas get initial props function and this
this lets us get some data for that
server-side rendering is so we're
passing in an ID and a type so this is
getting passed in from our server das
file in our routing function that we
have there and the ID in this case is
the faculty members name and then the
type should be is it faculty or the type
might actually be what department
they're in right so they're they're
gonna have a category each faculty
member is categorized based on the
department they teach in so I think
that's what that is here okay we're
bringing in some style sheets and
yeah we just map over each faculty
member and we have this faculty list
item okay
you know what I think we're gonna do I
think it may in this case it may
actually be faster to just copy and
paste and make a staff list component at
some point down the road I think it
would be nice to maybe combine these and
just have one component but I doing this
live I know like I'm gonna get a little
bit confused about how to make this
happen quickly enough so I'd rather just
do separate components that way I won't
break the components that are here that
already work and if we have to launch
without this I can just put a little you
know more info coming soon on that page
and we can still launch all right so
let's copy all this and let's make a new
page it's gonna call this staff list dot
J s let's paste that in there and first
thing I always do when I copy and paste
component is make sure I change the name
so we're gonna change it in several
places so we just changed the name of
the component but also we change the
name of the query staff list query we
haven't made this query yet so we're
gonna have to make a graph QL query as
well so that's kind of fun we'll get to
see some of that and then also this
staff list item component we're gonna
pull this as well and I need to bring
this in so let's get rid of this and say
staff so we're gonna need to modify this
component the reason I'm making separate
components is because the faculty
members have a lot more information that
we needed to display so I don't want to
mess with that I wouldn't
like conditionally say like if this
information is there then display it
otherwise don't display I may have that
set up already I don't remember if I did
so it's just going to be easier if I
mm-hmm it's gonna be easier if I I don't
worry about that right now and I'll
probably immediately make an issue in
github saying like hey can we refactor
these and combine them all and then
it'll be there for whenever I get time
or if one of you wants to take a shot at
it
then then we can work on refactoring
let's see okay so this component
basically what we want to do is make
sure so we definitely need the key we
need the profile name profile link it's
not gonna say faculty though it's gonna
say this is going to be a little tricky
so the link is actually going to be
admissions staff and we'll have to make
sure that in our router that this all
works out so we'll take a look at our
router a little bit later so we have
that the job title let me show you what
it looks like right now so let's go to
Franciscan dot edu this is the current
site so not the new one that we're
working on Franciscan dot edu slash
admissions staff I just want to see what
info we're already displaying to make
sure we at least display what users are
are used to seeing now so it looks like
we have name title a little bit of
content phone number and a link and an
image so we need those all those in
there so image title link
huh huh looks like I thought there would
be more info for the faculty but I think
we're gonna have more info here all
right so let's go phone and we'll call
this staff node fun I'm just assuming
that we've named that phone we'll have
to double check and see what its gonna
come through in our it come through like
in our API and let me change the names
of these because we don't want to say
faculty we own all this to say staff
this is multiple cursors feature so on a
Mac on Visual Studio code I'm pressing
command D to select them all and that
lets me change them all all at a time
like that so a lot of you probably know
that but I frequently get questions when
I do that so I thought I'd just just
throw it out there now okay all right
now would be a good time to make our
query so that we can actually get some
data in here and see what it looks like
we'll also need to go to our server Jas
file and make our route so that we can
navigate to this page so let's do that
first
so I'm gonna check and see we should
already have admissions in here oops if
you all want to check out this code on
your own the link for this repository is
in the description it's all open source
it's all one get up feel free to do what
you want with it but I need to find
where we're already setting routes for
admissions here we are
so for admissions when we get so this
first set with page is is telling our
application what component to use to
render this route so what we want to say
here is when you go to would be staff so
when the ID coming through is staff we
want you to use the staff list page and
the type and the quit site it doesn't
matter that doesn't matter for now in
terms of what the type is gonna be but
it will be it will matter in a minute if
we get so far as to do the single staff
member pages that will matter in our
routes that might end up being a tricky
one but we'll we'll figure it out when
we get there okay so this should at
least try to render that page which will
probably give us an error now so we need
to go into our queries and we're gonna
take that faculty list query and copy it
so let's make a staff so actually I'm
not I'm not really happy about how we
have the queries all separated out I
think it might have been a better idea
to put the queries in the component
because we're not really reusing queries
that much initially the idea was hey
we're gonna reuse a lot of these queries
but they end up not so a good refactor
might be to add these in the components
themselves but for now it works so we're
gonna leave it alone so let's change the
names here to staff instead of faculty
okay and we need actually make sure that
these fields are available to us so
let's use a tool called graphical if I
can find it
alright so graphical is let me make
everything bigger graphical is a really
awesome tool so graph QL is I'm not sure
what the right word I want almost static
self-documenting right so you don't have
to build like your own API Explorer when
you use graph QL you can just put your
endpoint URL into graphical and which is
a Chrome extension right and then it it
does this for you so let me just show
you what's what's going on here we can
go into here into our queries and then
see all possible queries so let's search
for staff and see staff member right so
we can go a staff member and let's check
out what what fields we can get from
staff members so in particular we want
to compare what we're getting here right
to staff members so actually we know
what we're going into the wrong way
let's go back out I forgot we we're
going to staff departments first okay so
staff departments let's see if I can
just pull this all in here
did I get them wrong I think I got yeah
I think I did that right all right let's
see go ahead and and paste all of this
in here
all right so staff departments were
named the slug equals I don't want it to
be name I want it to be admissions see
if that works
No
I'm not really that surprised that it
didn't work
unexpected name staff departments is
unexpected
all right wouldn't ready run
we
see
yes staff departments actually let me
check this out let's see what we had
before that worked oh okay all right
let's try that
and I assume we'll need another curly
braket let's see what happens now
oh no unexpected single quote probably
need double quotes alright oops and
cannot query field staff on staff
Department all right so what's the field
this should automatically fill and staff
members ok cool
see if that works hey check it out
alright cool so base like this really it
lets us play with our queries in real
time get results we don't have to be
messing on in our files right and we can
play with it here and then copy and
paste it over and it only work so
Michael in the live chat is saying
there's only one department true there's
only one department right now but
they'll probably be more at some point
so we're gonna plan on on more
departments ok so let's see alright
there's one thing that I still need
title slow content featured image job
title display name we don't have display
name right when you take that out cuz
that's not actually we can figure it out
let's uh let's go into WordPress where
we have all this data house and let's
find stuff I've so many custom post
types now I don't even bother looking
through them I just just feel fine
alright let's check out alright Corinne
has all the data I believe so okay so
okay we do have display name job title
phone all right so that value probably
is fun so I think we're good ok
oops let me check my time real quick
okay in about a little less than seven
minutes I'm gonna come back to the chat
and answer some questions so hang in
there if you've if you asked a question
so I I just need to put whoops just put
phone in here phone field okay oops and
I guess I need something else value
there you go
all right see that gives us what we need
all right let me take content out of
here for a second just cuz it's taking
up all of space okay yeah so we have
foam-filled value wonderful we have our
slug I don't
hmm actually I think our slugs gonna be
okay
but we should have
let me see what our urls are so I want
to make sure these right current source
oh okay
yeah that's right so I guess it is first
name first it's the opposite of what we
have for our faculty so staff is first
name first um we're trying to match up
the URLs to what's already there as much
as possible all right so this works I
believe we have everything that we need
so let's copy this I'm just gonna go
from where it says edges though so one
two so we have two curly brackets in
grab edges the reason so let me explain
this a little bit more so we're getting
first we're getting the department
called admissions and within there we
are getting all the staff members that
are associated with that department and
we're getting the last 100 right so I
put 100 in there there's no way we're
ever gonna have a hundred people in
admissions unless we grow significantly
as a school but that was a holdover from
faculty where some of the departments
are a little bit bigger
no where's no one is near 100 no
department but just wanted to be sure we
don't leave anybody out and then we're
gonna order them by alphabetically right
by the the slug so that's what we're
doing there and then within there we're
just grabbing all these values from each
staff member all right so we're getting
just the data that we need no more no
less so that's kind of the beauty of
graph queue or actually if you look
we're getting two different custom post
types which would normally if we're
using a REST API
we'd have to hit two different endpoints
for that but we only hit one endpoint
and we're able to get the data from from
both places so really cool you know the
alternate way with the REST API we could
hit one endpoint just the staff members
but then we have to filter all of the
staff members right by whatever category
right by this admissions for the staff
department category so grad Kiel just
makes it a lot easier
all right let's paste this in uh
so from edges down here I should have
paid attention to where this was okay so
there we go I think this is where we
need to be we're gonna paste that in and
save it okay so assuming that I didn't
miss any any names for the queries we
should be getting some data now so we
should be able to hit this endpoint so
admissions staff should give us what we
need so let's go here and you all might
be able to hit the endpoint already
admissions staff let's see what we get
oh okay
cannot resolve staff list item whoops we
didn't make our component okay that
makes sense
let's see just for the sake of testing
this quickly before my timer goes off
let's change this back whoops
let's change this component back oops
staff list we'll change it back to
faculty list
because I think this would work
let's see if it does okay
no to undefined forest a flesh
okay so what's undefined
we should be getting slug stop node just
my name oops
are we getting let's see up here I think
it should be staff member staff members
yeah let's try staff members nope
let's go back here and see yeah there's
slug staff members right departments
edges node staff members
staff data sequence staff
okay we're gonna have to troubleshoot
when we get back let me set my Pomodoro
timer here and let's fill out what we
need so we've consumed one Pomodoro
session right now so we're gonna put a 1
there I'm gonna scroll way up to the top
get to as many questions as I can rip on
was talk something about an address
account address you need to send to me
I'm not really sure what you were
talking about with the address so let me
know
Oshin says do you do any data analytics
equal Python etc no I currently don't
super interesting but haven't really had
an opportunity to do anything with that
yet let's see what text editor do you
use Visual Studio code so Rev says
tomorrow is my coding competition any
advice I guess try to calm down as much
as you can you know there's not you know
all the work you put into this point is
what's really gonna matter you know
there's not really a whole lot you can
do at this point so you you know might
as well just chill right and try to do
the best you can
so you think yeah try to get some sleep
to make sure you get good sleep
Chaitanya uh correct me if that's the
wrong pronunciation Chaitanya says
what's the best resource to learn
material you I their documentation is
actually pretty good I don't know of any
tutorials I definitely use it a lot in
my videos my live streams so you may be
able to learn some from the streams but
it's not exactly a tutorial so I would
say number one resource is their own
documentation number two my videos I
guess unless you can find
other videos which are probably gonna be
better for you Anthony says hi hey
Anthony Jacobson says oh okay hi
saying hi to Quincy from Haiti I did me
it's cool I'm pretty pumped that Quincy
is here as well
let's see MD says awesome site Thank You
Mohammed says what's the easiest way to
learn coding I definitely recommend free
code can't go to free code camp org and
start some of those lessons I mean there
if that's not your thing if you like
videos you know check out the free code
can you know videos if you like to read
more you can check out the medium
publication so that basically I'm not
saying free code camps the only way to
learn how to code but no matter what
your learning style is we have you
covered right so if you know there are
definitely other good places Udacity
code Academy there's other good YouTube
channels as well so you know there's a
there's a lot of options out there but
the main thing is no matter what you
choose and like to learn the material do
a little bit every day much better do a
little every day than to do a bunch of
one day and then take a week off or
something right
frank says hi from khou-tv ivory West is
West Africa hey how's it going thanks
for watching
Ambrose says nice Ambrose I love the
name I named my my youngest son Ambrose
Joe P says well I'm not sure if it
supposed to be Joe P or Joep but says
what are some fun projects to work on
currently I don't know what to make you
know there are some lists online and I
believe on github - about like app ideas
so I would check out those lists and
just Google for like fun app ideas or
something and you know people have whole
lists of you know stuff different ideas
that they've had so that's that's your
best bet
Mohammed says I'm doing some software
engineering what language should I focus
on more it definitely depends on what
you're gonna work with but I agree with
Quincy's comment
starting with JavaScript JavaScript is
very versatile so it's gonna give you a
nice intro to programming and it's gonna
allow you to work on a lot of different
things so you can be eclipse you can
make mobile apps you can even delve into
machine learning VRA are data science
like there's a lot of different areas
javascript may not be like the main
language for this particular area but it
will let you have a little taste and see
what you like and then if you you know
feel the need to switch to another
language to specialize you're already
gonna have the basic programming
concepts down so yeah so that's is
anyway it's definitely good advice from
from Quincy okay I'm gonna write down
where I'm leaving off at and we're gonna
go back and do at least one more
Pomodoro session so
okay alright so if I didn't get to your
question this time I'll get to it next
time let's start that Pomodoro session
again and troubleshoots okay so here's
what we'll do
let's comment some stuff out and see if
we can get it to render and then that'll
give us an idea of where the the problem
might be all right yeah so definitely
not still not rendering okay
we have anything in here so I might
[Music]
you know what let's just read this
[Music]
this whole section we're gonna get rid
of and we're just gonna put in we should
have put that in and let's see if we can
get it to render now I still nothing
all right so it seems like our routers
working right so it's sorry this is so
small I'm sorry let me zoom in so it
seems like our routers working right we
put an admission slash staff in for the
URL and then it's trying to render pages
staff list je s right that's what we
wanted right the staff list jss what
we're working on so it's there it's at
that point the problem seems to be it's
not finding the data that it needs so
let's think about this
what's it being sent for ID and type o
[Music]
all right let's check this out so for
our faculty list I'm sorry our staff
list let's get rid of that and let's get
a staff list so for this for this name
we're taking this this query string but
we really just need it to be admissions
for this one right so long term we may
have other departments so right now we
just have admission so maybe we could do
this because I think we're getting the
wrong value in I think that maybe the
the problem so let's just pass it so
into our query here
we pass a name
oops it's
sorry let me think about this for a
second are we even passing in props ID
interesting so the type doesn't even
really know weight this props tight
alright that's what's getting passed
into the staff list query
so we not really even using the type hmm
all right I may be missing it but it
seems like we're passing in type and we
don't need the type
okay that's fine that's something that
we can just refactor later it's not a
huge deal but what we're gonna do here
is we're we're gonna pass we're normally
passing on this ID in instead we're
gonna pass in admissions and now I think
we're safe to bring these back at least
some of them back oops
are we in different stuff faculty list
item is not defined
oops
yay okay cool
all right that worked let's uncomment
the rest now it's not gonna display the
phone number now because we haven't told
it to display the phone number we're
just passing it in as a prop oops cannot
read property phone of undefined whoops
yeah so it's not just phone it's phone
what did we call that let's go back to
our query and phone field and then value
so phone field value okay Oh fun field
of undefined
all right let's check this again
fun-filled oops not staff listen staff
there we are
all right hey check that out okay so we
have these cards now we're probably
going to need changes change this up
right so we currently now I mean maybe
maybe there's room for you know some
difference but currently there's this
little message from from each one of our
admissions staff members so we may have
to switch it up to something more like
this list or potentially if we wanted to
keep that card look like we have now we
could just you know make the cards full
with that's another option so I'd say
let me make sure I want to see if these
what these links are doing if they're
taking us to the right page
no no yet I you know what I am I had to
sign some of my student workers to
change up these links cuz they're the
wrong links were in them which one's
gonna work I think yeah this one should
work it's gonna give an error but I just
want to make sure yet that that's the
right URL okay all right cool so this
page works like in terms of data and
everything that works so that's usually
the tricky part now we just need to
render that that content right that we
have that we have here and we need to
render this this text me this little
phone number here so that's where you
now doctor wants me to update right now
how about later okay my other screen I'm
in these update notifications
okay
Michael s what's the route again it's
it's Admissions / staff
steak so we're gonna want to work with a
different version of this faculty list
item and we have
I thought we already had a like a
full-width component that we could use
but I guess we don't see what this one
is
no this isn't it you know what we must
have I or somebody else I don't remember
who who did this particular one must
have changed this faculty list item
component at some point because it used
to be full with all right let's uh while
I'm in here I'm gonna switch up how our
styles are done I'm gonna flip them here
at the bottom okay and let's save that
and then let's copy this and I hate to
do this but this what we're gonna do
we're just gonna copy this component
make another component it's gonna be
staff list item J s my stomach is like
growling so I'm sorry if you if you have
to hear that okay so we have a staff
list item component and now let's get
rid of this let's go to our staff list
and change this up the staff list item
and we'll change this back to staff list
item okay now it should render this
instead which right now it'll be the
same thing should still render down the
types of bells
staff yeah yeah
she's verify it works all right great
so that works no we can start switching
things up so first thing we can do just
to see how these cards will look for
with is change it up we're using this
grid we can just get rid of all these
grid sizes and keep this extra small 12
this is a built-in component into
material UI which is our component
library so on extra small screens this
grid item is going to take up 12 out of
12 columns so the full width all right
that's what we're saying here and since
we haven't indicated any other size up
from there it's just gonna use this
value for every screen size so that's
the first thing we're gonna do let's
save that see how it looks see if we get
some more space okay it looks like we
may have a max width on these on these
cards hmm okay not not a huge deal let's
let's do some more and then see how we
need to change up that that max width
okay we need to change this is fine with
the name and the title that's perfect
that's what we want this is also perfect
we just need to add some stuff in here
so within our
it's okay so job titles so we're gonna
continue here all of these are like
conditionals so if we get a profile link
prop past n then we render this okay so
that saves us from getting errors if we
have incomplete data right so let's say
somebody adds a new staff member but
they don't put in a link for them well
we're not it's not gonna be an error if
we do it like this it's just not gonna
show the link because we don't have one
so that's why we're doing everything
conditionally so let's say this part is
I don't know content I'm gonna call it
content let's add this here so we're
listing out all our props here and then
here we're gonna say phone as well so
we're gonna say content so if there is
content then after the end then we're
gonna we're gonna render the content
inside of this so we're gonna use
typography and the component we're gonna
give it as just a P that might be the
default so it might not be necessary and
[Music]
within this
I don't know why it's not automatically
doing that anyway let's render our
content
okay so within that okay and actually
that's we could have probably done that
all in one line because it's such a
small amount but this will work so what
they should do is give us the content
wrapped in a P tag so let's see see if
we keep going the wrong way it doesn't
look like we got it all right let's
inspect this to see what happened
yeah it's nothing all right let's go
back here and see why content maybe we
didn't pass it in as content yeah we
didn't pass in content at all which I'm
assuming it's gonna be staff node
content so let's see how that goes
see but since we had that conditional we
didn't get an error right
we were conditionally rendering so it
said hey you didn't pass in the prop
content so we're not gonna do anything
which is what we wanted to happen
there's still nothing maybe that was the
wrong check out our console didn't get
anything in there
okay now let's double check and our
query just to see woops you know what
remember we took out content corral
content never put it back in we're also
gonna need to do something special with
content here you'll see in a second so
the contents coming in with all the HTML
tags included right so here's how we
fixed that this is gonna look like it's
not the right thing to do but it's fine
as long as you control the data coming
in you never want to do this if you're
allowing you know just anyone to put in
the data and display it right but we're
gonna say enter dangerously set enter
HTML and then that's where we're gonna
put in
I believe it's like HTML content I think
that's how you do it
and in that case we're just going to use
oh no no no what's going on here it's
secured rid of that there we go whoops
said how we doing know
am i doing wrong
maybe I don't need that all right let's
just try it with content and see what
happens no
yeah I am oh you know what I think I
need to double underscores let's try
that
Oh
all right I may have to look this up
James you said under HTML equals all
right let's look it up
am i doing wrong
if anybody sees what I'm doing wrong
please let me know in the live chat
otherwise let's try to figure out what's
happening okay so it's possible we can't
do this in a typography component so
before I let's just try this in a normal
P tag first see what's going on
still be a minute here whoops
all right here it says you have the
slash before closing of the typography
yeah I was trying to close it there Oh
double we're passing an object thank you
mate mayor let me know if I'm
pronouncing that wrong okay that makes a
lot more sense we need double so it all
right yeah for this this example wasn't
like what we were doing so that's why I
didn't show this but we need that double
so let's just see how it looks with the
P we can switch it back to typography in
a second so we're passing in an object
whoa interesting we got it for a second
and then it went away that's weird we
had that happen before I can't remember
why it happened though I can't remember
how we fix it if anybody remembers how
we fixed that before let me know alright
but that came up for a second let's use
typography though let's see if we can
get it to work with typography all right
wonderful works with typography and it
doesn't go away so what we can see right
this is is taking up a lot more and why
does this say about me is that really
what we have in here Wow I definitely
don't want that and I don't want their
phone number right there that's weird
and their phone number is actually
different why is the phone number
different
i'ma have to remember that and send a
message to my student workers to have
them go in here and clean that up and
make sure that everything is actually
working
that's so weird it's a totally different
phone number all right
okay my timer is up for that Pomodoro
session let's take another break and let
me go back to where I left off in the
chat so three okay Lucy says could
somebody tell me which video is a video
where this project starts okay so this
project has its own playlist so it's
it's project five so you can go to the
project five playlist on this YouTube
channel and it should be in an order I
don't remember if I have it in
chronological order or reverse
chronological order
but anyway that playlist has everything
so it should say day one
Aaron says hello hey how's it going
Abba car says I want to re-watch this
yeah for sure
it'll be available as a video on YouTube
basically like a few minutes after it's
over
Nina says what's WordPress got to do
with the react app that's where we're
pulling the data from so you don't
WordPress has nothing to do with react
really but that happens to be one of our
sources of data for this project they
said our only source right now
all right well not really cuz we're
grabbing some stuff from cloud datastore
Google cloud cloud bucket so yeah but it
doesn't WordPress doesn't really matter
it could be anywhere that we're getting
the data from but it happens to be
WordPress for this project
Cory asked what Pomodoro timer I'm using
this is pom-pom dot now dot Sh
let me copy and paste this in here so
one of our live stream viewers
Harshit who contributed significantly to
a lot of these projects
Harshit created this timer so it's
pretty sweet and I use it all the time
for my projects if any of you created a
Pomodoro timer and want me to check it
out and show it on the stream please
send me the link don't try to send it in
the chat because it always blocks the
links you can DM it to me on Twitter or
I'm on like all the social media so just
check the link in the description for my
youtube channel and then from there I
have links out to all my social media
and and you can just message me on any
one of them with the link and all I'll
try to use it on my one one of my
upcoming streams but see Erin says I'm
learning react right now question is how
do you get rid of this kind of imports
where you have the dog dog flash
something dot s CSS Bjorn says Aaron
look at literal imports okay yeah check
that out I'm I'm not like a hundred
percent sure about the question for that
so I'm just gonna go with the Oren's
answer here and if you check it out and
that's not wishing you need maybe kind
of a skating ask question again down
lower we can get to it a little bit
later let's see silento says hey hey
how's it going let me know if I didn't
pronounce your name right
lol Marsha says hello hey Cal yoke says
hello bro how are you not bad I'm pretty
good busy day busy day today but I'm
feeling good and excited about getting
this project done how are you doing
Catherina says hey hey how's it going
Austin says hello why was the decision
made to switch from WordPress to react
so we didn't switch from WordPress to
react were switched from Extron which is
an old content management system based
on the.net framework so react is being
used to build this we just happen to be
storing a lot of the data in WordPress
as a content management system because
it's easy for people who don't know any
code to enter data into WordPress also
comes built in with a nice REST API and
with the WP graph QL plug-in we can also
grab data with graph QL
okay Oh spoon would said the company
isn't legible in Mayan I'm sorry I'll
try to adjust the the font size now okay
let me check my time all right let's do
one more problem adoro session you
usually don't do three I mostly do too
but I really want to finish this you
know get it looking a little bit nicer
okay all right so I'm gonna go back now
we'll do one more Pomodoro session oops
and I forgot to change this too it looks
like my estimate is gonna be spot-on I
think we'll get this finished in one
more Pomodoro session okay so here's
what we're looking at right now oh I do
have to remember to get this data make
sure the data is correct for this one
though I'm gonna I think manually take
this about me out just so I can see what
it looks like without it I really don't
don't need that in there refresh that
should be gone there we are
whoa shoot and did it again
all right I'm gonna have to go back and
look at some of the old streams and
remember why why this was happening okay
content coming in there we need our
phone number so let's pop in that phone
number here and I want to
you know let's grab this for now and
just use this to put in our phone number
okay whoa wait a second count east you
know we had this decode HTML function in
here the whole time and I forgot about
it okay
this projects been going on so long I
don't even remember what's in it now to
be honest I didn't write this this
function somebody else did this and I
can't remember who did it so if you're
the one that did that let me know and I
will give you a proper shoutout for this
but thank you for writing this all right
so let's let's do this properly let's
get rid of dangerously set enter HTML
after all that and I don't even need it
okay and we're just gonna put in the
code HTML we're gonna add content in
there and that's gonna take care of our
issues with the HTML and add typography
in there wonderful and then in here
we're gonna put phone which I believe
that is what we brought that in as we'll
figure it out if it doesn't work so we
got a phone coming in there and probably
could yeah let's leave it like that
we'll see if we actually need a label
like right now the current site has a
label it says like text me or something
like that I don't know that we need that
oh no it's not working
hmm our decode HTML was not working
why not because I guess it was it was
not meant to do that
let me go back let's go back to the way
it was even though it didn't work we'll
figure that out later all right let me
switch this up and I'll put in phone
it's you good whoops no no no okay we
definitely need to make this bigger
let's take a look at what we're doing
here with our alright so we have a max
height we have a height Animax with okay
we don't need to worry about the height
the height really comes into play when
you have multiple columns because you
want them to be the same height if
they're all gonna be in a row it won't
look as weird right if they're the same
height and we have this max width of 600
pixels let's bump that up to 1200 and
see what it looks like woah wow that's a
lot of content let's I didn't realize
there's that much content in some of
these okay let's check this out let's
check out Barnardo's entry here and see
let's see what we can do
you know what we need we're definitely
going to need to have we need to have an
excerpt for each one of these and then
the full amount of content okay yeah so
we just we need some work here and again
the phone numbers wrong I don't know
what happened there okay
[Music]
all right so let's look at one where the
the data is actually more realistic here
so this one is is more realistic so
let's get rid of yeah let's go and I'm
just going to manually edit this one for
Corinne worse yet I just I just need one
example of what the data is supposed to
be and if that looks okay then we're
good and then I can just assign someone
to correct all the rest of the data put
that in there like that
and this format okay now let's get rid
of all this
okay
now we'll update that and hopefully get
a better idea of what this is gonna look
like oops
see
all right that's killing me why am I
I cannot remember
[Music]
it's the phone number shown on yeah I
know show no maybe it it has something
to do with uh setting the dangerously
set under HTML
all right well regardless of what's
going on here the images are
[Music]
kind of see like this image is
definitely not a big enough image for
the student to work so we need we may
need a different solution cards might
not be the the solution here you know if
we could do more like well more like we
have here where they're just separated
out with just a little divider maybe
that might be better okay all right
mayor says it's because of nesting P
tags awesome awesome
I yeah that's that's gotta be it
okay so let's check this out
why is
okay
let's see if we can put in
yep that was it so this is a pee tag and
then WordPress is putting in adding in a
pee tag I believe that's what's
happening so it's just that was the
problem before okay so now we have a
better idea
but obviously the image is messed up
here I wonder if our image has a max
just this image type of max height what
are we putting on the air
yep the image has a max height whoa yeah
this is no good well now actually it's
not gonna be this this long so this is
more reasonable
this one this one got a more reasonable
size but we get down here like the image
size is just not good enough to handle
that and that's not even that long
all right like content-wise this is
going to be okay once we get the content
switched around but the images are going
to be an issue
yeah
now let's see what we're doing here with
images for common time
where's that max-width coming in there
max height I'm sorry oh okay
sir CSS
hmm
let's see if we can remove this CSS file
completely and if it if it's okay
so we are bringing in in our staff list
page we're pulling in this faculty list
CSS let's comment this out and see what
happens
you know refreshes to be sure I did
nothing all right I think this is fine
everything looks oh no way you know what
it went back to this I thought we just
took this out
Oh faculty lysias this is the season's
probably wanted to take out all right
let's bring this back in even though I
didn't really see any difference okay
all right so that did make a difference
suspect just to verify yeah we're not
pulling that in anymore
okay I'd say at this point that's about
all we can do until we get the data
switched around because when we're gonna
be pulling from a different area instead
of pulling in from the content we're
gonna pull in from the excerpt at least
for this so we'll leave it as is the
only other thing that I guess I'd like
to do maybe is make this a clickable
phone number see how much time we have
yeah ten minutes all right we can make
this a clickable phone number and then
yeah I kind of want to think about these
pictures and see just kind of think more
about how I really want to display these
these are the these are the actual sizes
of some of these images so yeah you see
some of them are just not well yeah
they're not nearly big enough to be able
to fit the card sizes that we're gonna
have so we need to rethink yeah we
definitely need to rethink this or get
images that work even this placeholder
images is it big enough we get probably
using SVG for this instead that might
not be a bad idea okay yes
let's go to where our phone number is
being pulled in wait a second how we
gonna do this we just need the the raw
number it's gonna be a little bit harder
than I thought
so now let's see I've never tried to do
this before you'll see what I'm talking
about in a second let's let's let's just
try it for staff list item we're gonna
take where we're putting in our phone
number here and we're gonna do an object
so what is called a template literal
sorry template literal it's es6 or yes
2015 syntax so actually let's let's do
this
so we're gonna do ya within our
JavaScript we're gonna make a string and
inside that string we're gonna say yes
it's gonna be within a span and we're
gonna put in an a tag and then our href
is gonna say tell write and then we're
gonna drop back into JavaScript land
we're gonna put in phone which I don't
think we need to Dakota HTML on phone
cuz it comes through as a number anyway
so we could probably get rid of it here
as well and I think we'll be fine all
right so we're pulling in our phone
there our phone number so we need to
close out those quotes we can close out
this a tag we're gonna put in
another variable right so we got to put
it in the dollar sign curly brackets and
then we're gonna close out our a tag and
then we'll close out our string put in
on another curly bracket to close out
JavaScript let's make sure did this work
why are you not working I think it works
it's just the syntax there we are
the syntax highlighting needed to catch
up okay so what they should do is make
this link clickable with a phone number
here let's see if it works oh no all
right it took all the because I have it
in typography that's why I did it okay
we're not gonna be able to do this
within typography
let's see if we can switch this up let's
you know what let's just put this into a
span
I like to use typography where I can it
comes with material UI and basically it
applies a standard for all your fonts
right but when I run into stuff like
that it's just a lot easier to drop back
down into you know your regular HTML
tags so we'll see how it looks
hmm
you know what I don't need this anymore
what am i doing okay
that was my problem that will at least
that time okay so now what we can do
here is get rid of this get rid of that
and oops we are gonna still need that
ready
unless it's just my syntax highlighting
messing me up alright let's see I might
not have needed to do that I think my
syntax highlighting maybe he just was a
little bit behind and that's why it
looked weird okay but check it out okay
we have this clickable number let's see
if it works
yeah it's asking me to open FaceTime I
don't want to but here's what I was
worried about though you can't really
see it but when I hover over it as the
the tail number it gives me the number
formatted exactly like this I wasn't
sure if that would be valid if it would
work so that was my only thing I guess
we'll have to test that out for sure to
make sure it still works cool
but now mm why did it not work oh you
know what some of these people probably
don't have phone numbers put in so this
is just what was in the content section
so that'll be that'll be better whenever
we get the content put in properly okay
cool so yeah so that's pretty much it's
pretty much done like I said the only
thing we're gonna do is switch it up so
instead of cards these will be just rows
with a little horizontal line in between
them and what that'll allow us to do is
use different size images it won't look
as weird so it won't be as obvious that
the images are different size we won't
have weird stuff like this happening
we'll just let the images be with their
normal sizes it'll look for some of the
images it will look strange because
they'll be way small we'll just set a
maximum limit on what the images can do
so we won't have gigantic ones on the
page
and then we can always go in later and
get better images you know you may have
to have our photographers so my
department we have photography people so
we may have to have them go actually
take a photo and then we can get
whatever size we want but that's not
realistic before launch right so we'll
make it look as good as we can for now
and later on and you know one day if we
happen to have all the images we need at
the exact size we need we could switch
up to something like this if we thought
it was nicer but I think this looks fine
right now well what I just described
will look fine
right yeah so but I'm gonna end of shame
because we've been doing this for quite
a while and I'm getting pretty hungry so
you just want to give you a heads up on
what's gonna happen with this if if
anybody really wants to jump in and
start doing some of this feel free to
open a pull request I need to catch up
and make sure I sign some of those tasks
I talked about and if there's anything I
need to put into an issue and get up
I'll do that as well and I need to push
out some of this code to the github
repository shell can see it and work on
it so that'll be the number one thing I
do anyway and the stream is I'll push
this stuff to get up right now actually
let me push it to get up right now
because I'm gonna answer some questions
that might take a look I want to make
sure if whoever wants to see this code
can see it immediately I'm gonna do a
git status just to see what's changed
okay I realize that I've changed some
other stuff that's somewhat unrelated
I'm not gonna do a separate commit for
that mainly just because of time I just
want to get through this commit and get
to the questions so we're gonna do a get
add and I'm just gonna put a dot to add
everything yarn cm okay so we have a
little kind of automated thing set up to
help us do a nicer commit message than
normal
if you don't have this set up it's
called committed and if you don't have
this set up then you just want to do a
regular get commit preferably with the
EM flag so you can put the message right
in line we're gonna say we had
new feature because we did and let's say
we add staff list page and staff list
item component yeah we did a bit more
than that we did queries and stuff but
if anybody really wants to dig into that
commit they'll see what changed
no breaking changes and I don't think
that affects any open issues so we're
gonna leave it alone if it did effect an
issue we can put it in right there and
it would automatically get tagged or
closed that issue so tests are gonna run
will see if they pass we may have to
update our unit test I'm hoping we don't
all right cool it looks like we won't I
don't know those were in dentists where
it was it yeah
all right cool we passed everything I'm
gonna do a get push ok now everything
should be up to date on the gate repo if
it's not up to date for you refresh it
it should be now I'm gonna go where we
left off at in the chat control 30 and I
need to take a drink because I've been
talking a lot I'm going to drink some G
fuel if anybody works for G fuel and
you're watching I'm open for a
sponsorship
okay
okay Julio as if I will upload a stream
of UJS I don't have any plans to do that
anytime soon because my streams are
almost always what I'm doing for work
and right now we're doing pretty much
everything with react
I do think it'd be cool to work with you
so if I'm gonna work with you it'll
probably be a side project in that case
I'm a stream it may be just on my on my
youtube channel so if you're interested
in saying that to tell you truth for
those of you who subscribe to my channel
my my personal channel you know I've
been slacking on that lately so I
apologize I have a whole list of topics
for videos that you all have requested
from me I really really want to get to
that I mean things are just always busy
right not only with work and with my
clients on the side but also you know I
have four kids so I'm gonna really try
to put out some content because I know a
lot of you are subscribed to that and I
don't want to leave you hanging and I
know even some of you have gone onto my
patreon and are helping to support me in
doing that so I haven't forgot about it
I do want to put out content so I'm
gonna try to make it a priority after I
get this site launched which will
hopefully happen next week that's just
gonna take a lot off me mentally and
time was so I'm hoping I'll I'll be able
to do that so if anybody has any ideas
for stuff they really want to see for me
to either do a stream or pre-recorded
video on my youtube channel please let
me know you can put it in a lab chat
here you can DM me or whatever you want
I'll add it to my list of stuff and and
hopefully get something made soon
Lewis says hello hey how's it going
Matthew asked where did you study so if
you wondering where I studied coding I
did that on my own so mainly free code
camp code Academy Udacity I think I did
like one udemy course or you to me
I'm sure you pronounced that a ton of
YouTube tutorial videos dev tips channel
was really active back in the day and I
watched them same way with learn code
Academy Channel they're still around
there's not as active let's see I mean
books blog art blog post documentation
you know all that in terms of like
formal studies my degree my undergrad
degree is in business I specialized in
particular in economics and finance and
I did that at West Liberty University in
West Virginia in the United States so
literally this school was like in the
mountains right and in this tiny little
town with cows there's not even a gas
station but it was a nice little school
it felt like you're in a private school
but it was actually the cheapest school
in the state and West Virginia is one of
the poorest states in the United States
so I didn't have any student loans
because it was so cheap which is great
anyway if you want to know more in
detail about my studies you can ask me
stuff and and I'll answer let's see I
lost my place sorry
William says this is great awesome I'm
glad you like it
albrecht says view j/s is well the
greater than sign so if UJS overreact
i don't know i haven't really used view
so i can't say i've heard good things
about you but my take on now granted
I've never used view so take that into
consideration my take on view versus
react at this point is I see a lot more
jobs for react than I do for view it
could just be because I develop with
react so I get targeted stuff you know
that coming
you know when recruiters reach out to me
it's with react stuff so who knows but
react is used as far as I know react is
used by more more companies and there
are more react out there okay maybe it
won't always be like that but that to me
gives react the edge if your goal is to
try to get a job you know with an
established company if that's not your
goal and you just want to build cool
stuff and you know go with you
also I mean I just I really I do like
react I think they have a good team
behind react there's a good ecosystem of
things that work with react like
material you I react router so anyway
that's my take on it
I have I have no hate for view though
right I'm not I have nothing bad to say
about view so if you like view that's
awesome I think there are people making
awesome things with you and with react
and with angular and probably with a ton
of other things so my thing is you just
you got to use what's right for you and
for your project you know based on the
requirements of that project and and
your abilities
albrecht says you takes most nice things
from react to an angular it's just as
you may see on github view leads but of
course it's personal stuff which you
could yeah yeah I agree that's true view
did surpass in terms of stars on github
view did surpass reacts so that's true
which I mean I don't know what's as a
metric you know stars are kind of
ambiguous right you know what does that
really mean
right that's what to me like for me
personally like I love coding coding
would be my hobby if I didn't already do
it all the time and get paid for it but
you know coding primarily for most
people I think is a way to make money
right so I think a more valuable metric
for a framework if you're trying to make
money is how many companies are already
using it right have they invested in it
because they're not likely to switch
right most companies once they invest in
something especially the bigger
companies they're not gonna switch for a
while so even if it turns out that view
is actually better than anything else
nobody's gonna switch the view if
they've already put in money and to
react or angular they're gonna stick
with it for at least a couple of years
so in terms of that like finding a job
even if you is better I'm not saying
one's better than the other but the
suppose like let's suppose view was
better just the fact that so many
companies are already invested in
angular and react is gonna say okay well
I might have a hard time harder time
finding a job with you as opposed to
react alright but so that's I I usually
recommend react for those reasons has
nothing to do with the quality of you as
as a library alright Joe says hi there I
am
a master's engineering in computer
science with six years experience and
C++ Linux real time then seven years
into teaching what are my chances of
reorienting my career again as a
full-stack developer well to be honest
with you I mean youyou have a very
impressive background so if you can
catch yourself up on some of the latest
in the full-stack world then I think
you're fine I mean you you probably have
a better grasp on computer science like
foundational principles then you know 90
plus percent of people on full stack out
there all right and that's nothing
against those people it's just you know
a lot of people that are full stack
developers right now you know the newer
developers probably didn't get a
traditional computer science education
because they didn't really need it to
get a job or to do their job right so I
think you have a value especially it
seems like larger companies like some of
your leaders in tech when you look at
their job descriptions they they tend to
favor people with a stronger computer
science background that may be changing
but from what I've seen you know I'm
thinking of like Google you know looking
at some Google jobs they definitely like
that if you have a strong computer
science background even if you're going
to be a front-end engineer it's it's
still there at least it was the last
time I checked out a job description so
that's going to be a definite like plus
for you you your thing would just be you
need to prove to companies that you can
build modern applications with the
latest technology so you're gonna want
to brush up on something like react you
angular build some progressive web apps
to put in your portfolio that's I I
don't think as long as
you are gonna enjoy it and be able to
you know switch and learn things you
know quickly I I think you'll be you
know very valuable if I was looking to
hire someone and you had that background
plus you had some really nice stuff in
your portfolio in terms of like modern
web apps like my only thing would be
like I don't know if I can pay this
person enough to want to come here
really because I think you're you're
definitely in a good position
Nino's says what is with styles I see
that a lot in your app yeah so that's
just what we need to use for form it's
your UI when we want to pull in our see
if I can find an example real quick
so we have this with styles in here and
that allows us to pull in and just use
use styles like this okay so that is the
the way and material UI that we bring
that that in so if you want to know more
about that I just check out the
documentation for material UI and how we
implemented that so I I never really had
reason to dig deeper into all the
theming options for material UI I just
use a little bit of them so I'm not
really comfortable explaining even more
in-depth as to what's going on behind
the scenes but that hopefully I don't
point you in the right direction if you
want to research it a bit more
Hyperion Jupiter says I'm passing out
just by looking at his codes why is it
is it ugly is my code just so sloppy or
what Razvi says try Adonis J s instead
of Express j s
alright I've never tried Adonis I
haven't even read up on anything about
it can you
Robb's if you're still around could you
explain like some of the then maybe the
differences between Adonis and Express
and like why would we want to use Adonis
instead of Express
Michael Creole says that Burt Reynolds
died so that stinks if you know what
Burt Reynolds is was was an actor right
so yeah I'm not sure I'm gonna he had to
have been pretty old at this point I
mean I haven't most of the stuff that he
acted in was when I was a lot younger
right
Oh mayor says your bid off with
pronunciation but it's fine is is it my
ear let me know I really do want to
pronounce it correctly so I don't I
don't want to be constantly saying your
name wrong
lovneet says target container is not a
Dom element how do I fix it I'm not sure
I mean just off the top of my head I'm
not sure about that error so I might
need to know a little bit more info to
help you with it
krishna says this is so interesting
awesome I'm glad that glad you find it
interesting lebanese says i'm a beginner
in react Jas any suggestions I would
suggest like just generally try to do a
little bit with it everyday that way you
won't forget what you've learned and
you're just kind of slowly built up and
you know don't don't be afraid to just
read like the react documentation
definitely take advantage of using
things like create react app to help you
just get started you you don't need to
know how to completely set everything up
from scratch to be good with reacts you
you really don't so don't you know don't
don't feel ashamed to you know kind of
use those things the same way with like
routing you don't need to make your own
router use react router or use something
like next Jas with a built-in same thing
with server-side rendering right you
don't have to do it yourself there's so
many good tools around that are really
like high quality so you could get
really overwhelmed and really kind of
slow yourself down if you try to go and
learn how to do these things from
scratch when it's really unnecessary
right you take advantage of the tools
that have already been built and a lot
of testing and work has been put into it
but fazil says good days bro i like this
channel awesome I'm glad you like it
programmer says what are you listening
to I'm just listening to Spotify so it's
it's just a bunch of different songs
it's one of like the daily mix channels
so to be honest with you it sounds like
I don't know like pop music really I
actually try not to put when I'm doing a
stream I try not to put music on but
like I really like is then it's
distracting I don't want to like pay
attention to it so it's better to just
have some random stuff going but the
music in the background helps me number
one I can't hear what's going on outside
my door so it's not distracting me
number two it helps me to make sure that
I I talk loud enough for the mic to pick
it up you're normally I'm I'm kind of
soft-spoken and I have a tendency to
mumble sometimes if I'm not really
thinking about it so this helps me kind
of overcome that so y'all can understand
what I'm saying
Oh No where the where the subtitles I
don't understand he says I'm really
sorry so we don't have subtitles for the
live stream YouTube does those automatic
subtitles so you may be able to catch
the recording I mean I don't even know
if you can understand what I'm saying
now I'm sorry you may be able to catch
the recording and have the automatic
subtitles work we don't really have
anybody that will like do the subtitles
manually if anybody's interested in
doing any subtitles for for this channel
or for any of my videos let me know that
would be awesome I'm sure we can we can
do that and I definitely give you a
shout out like constantly on my stream
you V design says this is Carl from
Twitter don't really understand
everything just digesting everything and
so I bring myself up to speed
oh yeah cool um feel free to ask ask any
questions you know I'll be happy to like
stop and go back over what I'm doing so
and that goes for anybody you know I if
I lose you on something let me know I'll
definitely go back and explain I want
this these streams to be as helpful as
possible to you all let's see this is an
interesting character so I need to go do
a little little translation here
Melo's so me lo says Jessie what college
did you go to or high school so the
college I mentioned earlier was West
Liberty University when I went there was
called West Liberty State College but it
like upgraded to a university so that's
what it's called now and for high school
I went to a high school called we're
high
so we're high school in in the town of
Weirton West Virginia so it was it not
that big of a high school I think there
were around 200 students in my
graduating class so anyway that's that
was where I went
na naman says I'm pursuing a Bachelor in
computer science third or final year I
have a little bit of knowledge about
cc-cold sauce java HTML can you give me
advice in what language I should focus
on more it entirely depends on what you
want to do right also Naaman says and
what is trending in the market now okay
honestly I feel like I say this a lot so
sorry but javascript is just it's really
big right now there is so much so like
everything on the web is JavaScript
right it has been for a while but even
more is being built in JavaScript you
know with electron thing like desktop
apps for Mac Linux and Windows you have
Android and iOS apps being built with
things like react native and ionic you
have now
data science stuff being done machine
learning stuff being done with things
like tensorflow and brain j/s you can
you have AR and VR stuff being built
with I can't remember what the libraries
are but you know there are JavaScript
libraries to do almost anything that you
could be doing and
future science so if you're not sure
what you want to do try javascript if
you know what you want to do then maybe
you want to research okay so from what I
understand about things like data
science and machine learning Python is
the route to go if you're really into
just building for Android Java or Kotlin
iOS is Swift we're trying to think what
else if you really want to go into like
content management systems like
WordPress or Drupal
those are PHP based so it really depends
on what you want to do right hopefully
that helps if you give me some more info
on what you're into maybe I could kind
of give you some more targeted advice
Meyer says Adonis J s is laravel of
JavaScript so I don't know that much
about laravel though right it's a is it
PHP framework I think it is I it doesn't
help me that much okay let's see
Wladimir says what is the best books for
starting to learn javascript for
beginners there's a whole series and you
can actually read it for free I believe
it's on github it's called you don't
know J s great series
there's also another book available for
free online called eloquent JavaScript
those two books I think are awesome and
they're great places to start out not
only will they teach you Java Script but
it'll teach you a lot of like basic
computer science concepts MD says how to
build a real-world application with
react and how many projects do I have to
- for my own advanced user that's really
a hard question to answer so I mean to
build a real-world application I mean if
you build an application like that's
it's a real-world application right if
it does something like that's it now if
you're talking about like actually
getting paid to build something I mean
there you'll need to actually find
someone who's willing to pay you to
build it but it's hard to say how many
projects you'd have to work on right
because projects like you know you could
do a project it's like a weekend project
and it's this little thing right and it
does one thing or you can do a project
like what we're working on now that
we've been working on literally all year
right we started I believe in January
for this project so it really depends so
my advice is just each time you do a
project try something new try to push
yourself a little bit further and then
you at least you'll know you're
improving right and you know that's
really all you can do right just keep
trying to get better
okay
okay so someone is typing and so I think
Melo's is typing in Croatian here is
that it says you can find free books in
PDF format okay cool so we're talking
about Vladimir's asking about the books
so I got my Google Translate open the
other window so I think he says you can
find free books yeah
ome lo said Serbian not Russian I'm very
sorry I did not mean to to confuse that
so you're right I shouldn't assume that
also Mila says are apps with with books
on the Google Play Store david is react
better than angular or is it about the
same say truth I haven't used angular
since angular 1 so I can't really give
you a great answer to that reactant
angular are not exactly the same so it
could be that angular may be better for
some things and react is better for
other things the thing that I found
really is you can build awesome stuff
with anything and you can build terrible
stuff with anything it depends on how
you use it right and one framework or
library is not going to be the answer to
every everything right so better to just
say look what fits the situation in
terms of what resources do I have what
are the project requirements you know
what how much time do I have and what do
I already know right now you know what
is my team though so in some cases maybe
it's gonna be rad maybe it's gonna be
angular maybe it'll be view may be obese
like amber who knows I mean who knows
what it's just gonna be the hail says I
want to become a back-end slash full
stack developer so do you think getting
a degree in computer science is worth
the money and time or just at end of
boot camps of self teach here's my my
normal advice for this now take it take
into consideration this I live in the
United States I don't know what the
situation is like in other parts of the
world in terms of what's required for
jobs and how much college costs so
here's my advice if you have
scholarships that are gonna pay for your
education or your parents are gonna pay
for it go for it
okay it may come in handy at some point
and if you're gonna get it for free then
take advantage of that right if you have
to pay for it and it's gonna cost a lot
and you're gonna have to get take out
loans and go into a significant amount
of debt don't do it you're gonna set
yourself back a lot and it's gonna
severely restrict your options later on
right when when you don't have to pay
you know let's say I don't know like six
hundred plus dollars a month through
your student loan payment then you have
a lot more options to say like you know
what I'm gonna I'm gonna work on this
project even though I'm not going to
make that much because it's gonna get me
in with this company that could lead to
something or I'm gonna be able to work
with this technology and it's gonna look
really good on my portfolio right you
may not be able to say that you may have
to say you know what I'm gonna have to
take this job because it pays a lot or
it pays enough right now working with
some old technology you're doing
something that's not really gonna
advance my career just to pay the bills
right so you may think like college is
gonna give you an advantage but it may
not it may set you back in in terms of
what you can do after school to really
put yourself in a position to get the
job you want right so but like I said it
definitely depends on your financial
situation and and what's going on and
what you want to do right if you want to
if you want to get into like you said
get a front back-end or a full stack
developer you could definitely get a job
without the degree but it's not like
that for not even for every job in
computer science right so definitely do
your research and especially like in
your area - right I don't know what it's
like in other job markets in other
countries
Rasen says I'm starting my first
developer job on September 17th got some
advice to give I'll work with react oh
yeah cool um congratulations first of
all that's awesome
definitely if you can come back to his
stream after and let me know how it's
going let me know your jobs one if you
can't come to a stream just like DM me
or something on Twitter let me know I'd
love to hear how it's going but here's
my advice when you first start out a job
listen a lot right don't worry about
proving yourself right off the bat I
know it's a big temptation to try to
like I got to prove myself but eh they
believed in you enough to hire you right
they went through that process that
expensive difficult process of finding a
new employee and they put their faith in
you
you don't have to convince them right
they've you've already convinced them so
don't worry about trying to prove
yourself because sometimes you know you
could you could end up looking foolish
if you're trying too hard to prove
yourself right so instead try to listen
way more than you talk right because you
need you want to figure out what's going
on in your organization like not just
technically but also like who how do
things work in terms of the
relationships you know in your company
right who's now like it'd be great if
everybody was nice and perfect right but
we're not so it's like who is
trustworthy right who's telling you good
information and who's maybe not telling
you good information right who can you
trust to talk to honestly about things
and who should you maybe like watch what
you say around right so you want to be
able to take all that in and and just
kind of sit back and also like you don't
want to accidentally offend somebody
right if you step in and say why are we
doing it like this that's a terrible
idea
you don't realize like maybe your boss
was the one that came up with that idea
right that's you know that's a mistake
right so
sit back right you will have plenty of
time to prove yourself when you actually
start working on your projects veda but
that's my advice at first when you come
into a situation like be very friendly
be friendly to everybody certainly if
somebody talks to you like be friendly
and talk but you know in general like
sit back and and relax you know I don't
think anybody expects you to come in on
day one and do amazing things right so
just like take your time to get a feel
for what's for what's going on there
anybody else has any other advice for
starting a new do developer position
please let browser I know in the in the
chat
melosa is trying to teach myself and
it's not easy okay so that was in
response I think to somebody else we'll
skip the jbs what kind of tech is
typical for a front-end dev javascript
HTML CSS that's that's your basics of
you know every front-end devs going to
know that or at least they should if
they don't I'm not sure what like what
they'd be working on but yeah your your
front-end does and in a call from
somebody I don't recognize the number
I'm just trying to remember if I had I
don't think I'm expecting it cause so I
think I'm good yes so that's your basics
now if you want to branch out and do
other stuff you know so you can get into
react are you to talk about testing
maybe you're gonna use jest or something
like that like you want to interact more
with like like REST API is and things so
like there's a lot of different routes
you can go to start branching out and
your knowledge but your basic stuff that
you should for sure know HTML CSS
JavaScript
David says I'm about to lead a software
development team for the first time and
I'm not an experienced developer myself
what should I be concerned about you
know what I would say if you're gonna
lead a team
just make sure now I don't want to give
you that advice here but if you're not
as experienced as some of the people
you're gonna be leading don't be afraid
to admit that and be honest about it
because it'll probably be obvious at
some point to those people right so I'd
be open about the fact that you know say
hey like I want people on my team that
know more than me or different things
than me right to fill in those gaps and
make it clear that your job in
particular is to make sure everybody
works together all right it'll be a lot
more clear that maybe you don't that
it's okay that you're leading people
that may be better than you at being a
developer right because your number one
job is not just the coding your job is
to make sure that the whole team works
together right so kind of like
establishing that right off the bat is
good but then balance that too and I
know this is gonna be hard to do but try
to balance that with yes I'm gonna I
really want your opinion on I respect
your opinion but at the end of the day
like if I'm leading this I'm gonna have
to make some calls that may be different
than what you suggest so you're just
trying to have that balance of you know
respect going both ways you know now I
how you do that is it's really gonna
depend on the personalities of the
people that you're working with - it'd
be hard to say for sure but hopefully
that helps a little bit
Mila says Jessie it is a hacker he got
your number joke I don't get it I don't
know what the joke is I'm missing
something and an Arabic says I'm very
interested in programming programming
I'm 30 years old and if dedicate myself
to this will I get hired or accepted by
companies or would they be interested in
someone who's over 30 years old oh yeah
for sure for sure I wouldn't worry about
that
your there's like AI seems to be a lot
of apprehension about like age and the
tech industry but if you can prove that
you can do the work that's what's most
important right so I wouldn't worry
about that just focus on being able to
do to do the work
Vladimir this is he's gonna start it to
build a site for survival cut many
skills that's cool
if you start building that share that
that'd be cool I want to check it out
and our back says is a Cisco certificate
good to get a job well if you want to do
Cisco Networking then yeah it's it's
good it just depends on what you want to
do I I don't really know what the job
prospects are for that right now so I
can't say whether or not it's it's gonna
get you a job for sure or not
neither says I'm referring to the
unknown number which called you I'm
terrible oh okay
bye bad haha I totally forgot I was
getting a call I shout okay it was my
mortgage company so I'm looking to get
like a home equity loan to do some
remodeling in my house so my wife has
wanted to remodel the house for years
and so I finally am like okay let's get
this he'll be the loan and and we'll do
this so anyway it was somebody from the
loan company calling me to remind me of
all the documents I have to send in
let's see I think I'm almost through
everything
JB says are you using a design framework
on the project yes so material UI is
what we're using David says thank you
for your advice Jesse best of luck to
you in the future
oh thank you I appreciate that okay I
got through all the questions if I miss
your question you know let me know in
the comments to the video or ask me on a
future stream or DMV or something but
yeah I definitely need to take a little
break here and get something to eat
and let me say well one more comment
I'll read this I mean that says you're a
lucky
you have a wife do what you love and our
happy best of luck to you too oh thank
you I really appreciate that
yeah I guess I mean I I have it pretty
blessed in terms of having a good wife
and a good good kids in your family here
so yeah so definitely try to appreciate
that
all right cool so and my throat is gonna
sore from from talking so but this will
probably be my last dream of the week
I'm gonna try to stream on Monday if I
can so and I maybe I'll try to stream
some of the like launch of the site if
possible because that might be kind of
cool to stream that so that'll probably
happen on Wednesday but until then have
a great day have a great weekend and
thanks again for watching